so robust forced us to take our very
philosophical notions of what it means
to think and translate it into a
physical mechanism or an algorithm that
can actually operate so we can wave our
hand about things like creativity and
self-awareness and use vague terms like
canvas of reality and things like that
we actually have to translate it into
something that works so robotics really
gives us sort of forces us maybe to to
take these very vague notions and
translate them to something concrete and
experiment with it that's what I love
about this whole areas it allows us to I
think make very concrete progress on
these age-old questions
well we tried to implement
self-awareness in robots we suddenly
come into all these new and exciting
directions that give us ideas of back
about what it means to be human for
example we might discover that hey the
ability to understand what somebody else
thinks process called theory of mind
which humans do all the time
he's very similar to self-reflection
thinking about what you think thinking
about thinking we see that in robotics
and that leads us to thinking maybe the
same is true for humans our ability to
understand ourselves is a special case
of our ability to understand everybody
these are very to me very profound
notions about what it means to be
self-aware what it means to be conscious
what it means to be human
ultimately what it means to be sentient
we also get to understand things like
emotions and understanding emotions
itself and then others all these
different things that are very vague
suddenly become concrete